hey fellas welcome back uh I know I'm
sitting kind of alarmingly close to the
camera today but I'm gonna kind of try
this one out uh yes I have bad skin
welcome to the party I'm a coder what
else is new so uh first of all quick
announcement thanks everyone for 7 000
subscribers I really appreciate that and
uh yeah I'm eternally grateful to all of
you especially those of you who have
been here since even like before I
collaborated with gorab or whatever and
got a few thousand people
um yeah again I'm making these videos to
help people mostly and the subscriber
count is not really what I'm optimizing
for at the end of the day but you know
to me it indicates that uh people are
gaining some you know usefulness out of
this Channel and that makes me a happy
guy you know I always want to try and
help and I think I'm doing that so far
so that makes me very happy Additionally
the more subscribers I get uh you know I
can stick it to this one Tick Tock girl
that I went out on a date with and she
was not into it so let's uh move on from
that and get into some content for today
all right we're back in Action I've got
the iPad in front of me so let's get
started so today I am going to be
talking about another race condition and
I do not mean Israel Palestine I mean
repeatable read which is also known as
read skew so basically the way I'm going
to go ahead and talk about this is by
doing the following with an example so
let's imagine I have a table that shows
all the bank accounts of the Kardashians
I know there are eight names on here
there might be more than that I'm sorry
I even know eight but you know don't
judge me whatever so the predicate of
this table let's imagine that we know
the balances must add up to a million
dollars they at one point did add up to
a million dollars and I'm going to make
the arbitrary constraint that basically
they can only exchange balances with
each other so there's always going to be
a million dollars of value in this table
okay so we have basically all the
Kardashians listed below and their
respective balances I got pretty lazy
finding two more names hence why Scott
has 300K so let's imagine that I'm doing
some kind of housekeeping work for the
family I'm going through the database
and telling everyone how much money they
have in their bank account so that's
going to require me to read every single
row of the database and then return all
of those values so it's going to start
something like this I'm going to read
Caitlyn I'm going to read Kylie I'm
going to read Kendall I'm going to read
Chloe I'm going to read Courtney and
then right before I read Chris Caitlyn
decides that she needs some more plastic
surgery so all of a sudden Chris the
mother of the family is going to send
Caitlin her hundred thousand dollars so
now Caitlyn actually has 200k
and Chris has zero dollars so basically
the invariant of the table still holds
right all these values do still add up
to a million but we had already read
that Caitlyn's value was 100K and now
when we finally get to Chris we are
going to read that her value was Zero
because this right has just executed in
the middle of our massive read right our
rights don't actually block reads and
we're still reading committed data this
entire time so there's no issues here
but now when we add up all of these
balances we're actually going to be
minus a hundred thousand because we
didn't account for the fact that Caitlyn
is going to be getting another hundred
thousand Midway through the read so that
is basically the idea of read skew we
have this table it has some sort of
invariant and ultimately due to a right
in the middle of some massive read
possibly due to an analytical query the
invariant no longer holds we want to be
able to see the database in a consistent
State and basically because we're doing
this long read and there were rights
interjecting it we weren't able to do so
so let's think about ways that we can
fix this and the way that I'm going to
propose starts with our friend the right
ahead log so let's go ahead and scroll
down so as we know every right that goes
into a database is going into our right
ahead log that's really useful for both
durability and atomicity and so for the
right ahead log it's just one list on
disk and all the rights are sequential
so what this allows us to do is actually
go ahead and order transactions so as
you can see you know if we're making
sure that writes and reads block each
other they don't necessarily have to so
I can take this one out but you know we
have a write at T1 we've got to write at
T2 we've got a right at T4 and basically
whatever hits the write ahead log first
we can assign a monotonically increasing
sequence number monotonically increasing
just means that it's going up by one
every single time but it's not a big
deal and you know same goes for all of
these other lines right here that we're
adding in the future they're going to
get sequence numbers as well so we've
now basically given all of our
transactions a number and for a given
transaction let's say we want to be able
to see a consistent snapshot of the
database at the time that that
transaction was written so let's see an
exercise of how we can actually do this
so let's imagine we have a bunch of
rights to our database which again has
the account balances of a bunch of
Kardashians and we want to basically see
the database snapshot at T15 well the
way that I'm basically going to propose
that we do this is every single time
that a value gets overwritten instead of
just deleting that value what you do is
store all of the values with the
transaction number that wrote them and
then keep all of those values so as you
can see a transaction one basically said
that Caitlyn's bank account account
balance was 100K on transaction 6 it was
overridden to be 300K and on transaction
12 it was overwritten to be 200k the
point is here you don't have to actually
write a value for every single one of
the transactions but only the
transactions that modify the rows
themselves so these are going to be
relatively sparse it's not going to take
up a ton of extra storage in theory okay
so let's imagine we want to basically
see what the database was looking like
at T15 right so whatever transaction 15
was written so right off the bat we know
that something like this right here
which was written in transaction 17 is
invalid and the same goes for this right
that was done by transaction 22.
so to really find what we care about
from transaction 15 I'm going to draw
this line that basically cuts out all
the rights after transaction 15 and then
for all of the rows we're going to take
basically the most recent value that was
before 15. so in the case of Caitlyn
that's the right that was done at
transaction 12 so she has two hundred
thousand dollars in the case of Kendall
it was the right of transaction 15. so
she has a million dollars in the case of
Chris that key was only written at
transaction 22 in the first place so at
transaction 15 Chris doesn't even exist
there's no Row for Chris in the database
and then finally for Lamar it was only
written once at transaction three and
there's going to be 100K so basically
again the point is you don't delete
these old values but rather you store
them and so for these big reads that we
might have that take a long time to
execute we don't have to risk seeing the
database at some inconsistent state but
rather we can use a database snapshot
and that right there is the premise
behind snapshot isolation so guys I hope
you enjoyed this video relatively short
but hopefully simple my point of this
new series is to make sure to really
hone down on topics and not brush over
them like I at times did in my previous
series snapshot isolation I probably
covered in all of 30 seconds in my
previous series and while that's good
for some people for others it is you
know good to make sure to really cover
every single edge case and make sure
that you really understand it so anyways
guys have a great night wishing you all
the best and thanks again for all the
love